I
[Music]
nothing bad ever happens on Christmas
Eve nothing bad happens on Christmas Eve
wish that was still the case for the
pearsons in the present on this is us
because something bad does happen now if
you haven't watched the show's fall
finale look away now the one thing I
cannot live without is you Toby and Kate
split is short-lived the to reunite for
Christmas consummate their holiday love
before tragedy strikes Toby collapses
and is rushed to the hospital is
conditioned by the end of the episode
unknown
chris sullivan who plays Toby opened up
to ET about the shocking cliffhanger
telling us quote it's definitely going
to keep people on their toes for a few
weeks while we take a break it was
shocking it's a difficult thing to have
to watch your character who I've come to
love and enjoy plane have to go through
something like that Chris of course
couldn't tell us what happens to Toby or
what actually caused the collapse but
jokes if he doesn't survive he could
come back as an angel we'll just have to
find out when this is us returns in
January
[Music]
you